we look at what randy dobneck has
done so far this year i mean there's
just not a statistic that's bad across
the board
that's a ball caught at third gonzalez
comes up firing and the game starts with
a sterling defensive play
by marwin gonzalez fairfield ready for
that ball moving down and in from
dobneck and marwin makes a terrific play
to catch the ball but then the speed at
which he was able to get up and get an
accurate throw watch this a great
backhand play and then no wasted time
throws the ball
on the money two down to hunter dozier
and he hits it well to right field
kepler is back
there's that overhang out there and
hunter dozier
it's his first home run of the year this
one goes to the opposite field
you can't pull him you got to think the
opposite field look at that that's a
cookie in the middle
right there beautiful inside out swing
dozier got plenty of power there
for target field and nice to see and
brady singer will make his fifth career
start
so now he hits a line drive that is
caught
by ryan o'hearn so three up three downs
he's been in a little bit of a slump oh
for his last 15
30 pitch alex goes after it and hammers
it deep to right
that's a way back and that ball is going
to be
gone home run alex gordon his first on
the road this year
and the royals have taken a two-nothing
lead
i'm going through a little spell here
but if i recognize a pitch out over the
middle
i can do something about it you would
have ground it out anyway
way to go alex good stroke
got him with a fastball up and riding
away and that's singer's first strikeout
today you set down the first
five look at the movement on that
fastball that takes off
so a walk with two out now buxton's
coming up
the pitch slider pulled to the left side
monday shovels to lopez at second they
get the force there
the inning is over
[Music]
and a block now is being called from the
twins dugout
and they will advance avila to third
base odyssey came
[Music]
twins have a chance to get a run without
a hit
and coming home as avila he'll score
polanco hit it on one hop to o'hern
and the twins get a run on a walk a wild
pitch a bawk and a groundout
from the stretch now singer deals and a
fastball called strike three at the
knees
brady singer one of his best pitches of
the day right there as he strikes out
his second on the day
yeah i mean just just attacking the zone
look where this strike is i mean that's
quality that's a quality strike here is
kepler the ball in the air twice once to
center wants to shorten
deep to right it's hit pretty well and
the twins
take the lead a two-run jolt
for kepler his sixth of the year
the ball leaked just a little bit back
into his barrel and he put a charge in
it
that's all about approach right there
just knowing what a guy's fastball's
doing knowing what he's trying to do to
you
say okay if that's it i'm just going to
look there number one
down for a hundred runners go and the
ball hit to left field
and rosario makes a sliding catch
they'll get a double play
what a catch by rosario picking it off
the grass before it hit the grass
and a line drive double play ends the
threat to minnesota
and a new pitcher for the twins is 6'5
240 pound right hander
trevor may here comes the payoff pitch
he'll swing and miss and strike out on
the off speed
from may so hearn strikes out the runner
at first one down
left side out at second bare handed by a
rise and he turns a double play
great play up the middle by luis and
eyes
bare handing the flip from polanco
polanco oh for three did drive in a run
with a ground ball in the third inning
he's gonna go squeeze play here comes
the pitch runner
and a beautifully executed squeeze play
with vargas scoring from third base the
safety squeeze and it's a thing of
beauty
sergio romo will come on
out in front of strikeout for the first
out of the ninth inning
half swing but he went and romo starts
his ninth inning
with back-to-back strikeouts
got him on the outside corner
strikes out the side and we have another
4-2 finish this afternoon's game going
to the twins